[Music]
[Music]
13 o clock
hey everybody Merry Christmas
this is actually going up on Christmas
Day you guys so yeah hopefully you guys
are having a good Christmas um you know
and you can sit around and listen to us
later on yeah we've already started the
Christmas feasting I think tomorrow's
Christmas Eve right yes it is all right
we're recording this on the Sunday
already cook the turkey a couple days
ago polishing that off and doing the
candied spiral cut ham tomorrow yeah oh
yeah we're such gluttons for holidays a
week of holiday food me [ __ ] up my
diet and trying to rest up the most
heavy liftin that a man does got Santa
got a light up Santa you can't really
see in here got Jesus this is that's
buddy Christ there buddy crap alright
cuz it's his birthday
[Laughter]
also we've got little like bean baggies
puffy Santa yeah I got bean bag my
grandma actually made that yeah and I
got I don't have a lot of Christmas
decorations so I kind of had to
improvise I got my intelligence glasses
yeah he got new glasses put these on you
immediately boost your IQ up about
another tenth is that let's make it
sound like I know what I'm talking about
yeah Anderson Cooper glasses give you
the news it's not fake news though but
it's honestly like look I have different
glasses on to but that is because my
cool little black flame framed reading
glasses broke broke and since it's
Christmas I'm too broke to buy another
pair these are tops reading glasses but
I'm using so I can actually see the
screen sturdy enough so I can have my
prescription is close to what she needs
so I'm not that blind I just need
reading glasses I don't need police
glasses in any other time I just need it
to see the computer screen in my phone
the same with me I don't got perfect
vision outside my arm's length yeah but
up close you know I need him to read
yeah we hit 40 just BAM and it happens
in like three months
yeah it was like for me it was really
quick cuz remember yours had been going
downhill a little bit like before me cuz
you're a couple years older but mine was
like actually really really good in fact
he would like call me in hey I need your
eyes like come in here and read this
tiny little yeah you know script on
these women like the back of a spice
packet or something and it's like just
in six months I just couldn't I just
like looking at it I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
right around 40 it just happens fast
getting old it's like three months three
months within three months you're blind
yeah up close yeah it's really blows I
can't even paint my [ __ ] fingernails
for that reason all right so yeah since
this is our extra special Christmas
special what I decided this you guys it
took me like so long because I think the
first year that we did a Christmas show
we did the obvious thing that you would
do which is like creepy Christmas
creatures we talked about Krampus
Belsnickel and all not a popular show
well because when you do seasonal shows
I guess like you know but yeah so and
then I think last year we did one about
we did kind of a biblical mythology one
yeah there was a way to Book of Daniel
and book of Revelation and so because I
so that's not really Christmassy but
sort of yeah most of it about that
either and this one I was like well I
want to do something Christmas related
but also that something like paranormal
paranormal like relevant to this show so
you got a good one today yeah so here's
one and this is actually some [ __ ] that
people have well one thing wasn't so as
it happened there were two very very
famous British alleged UFO sightings or
paranormal
phenomena type activity Rendlesham
forest is the chrismas UFO case like in
the same way that diehard the Christmas
action movie yeah you don't know that
it's the crew everybody knows that
Roslyn forest is Christmas time but then
like not another one - yeah and then I
was saying because I was saying oh well
Rendlesham forest the very famous
tarnishing forest incident happened on
December 25th 26th and then while I was
looking around I found another one that
is much much less well-known called the
warminster thing and this also although
there had been like little hints of it
like beforehand the main bulk of the
action started on Christmas Day of 1964
and went on for several subsequent years
and it's like it's funny because I had
never heard about it and it seems like
my people a lot of people hadn't really
heard of it like I found some stuff
about it but not a lot that was super
clear I know I know quite a bit about
Rendlesham I've been looking at that
case off and on for many years I have my
own opinions about it you know most
aspects I think I know kind of what
happened with that case and be an
ex-military I think I have something to
contribute in my opinions I think I can
contribute into this into the the
scenario in which this case happens
because being at Fort Campbell and being
deployed overseas in a couple different
places including that the DMZ and Korea
and some stuff in Egypt we had to do
missions like that like perimeter
security and internal security of basis
so I know how that [ __ ] goes and I know
what it would be like if you filed
reports like this with how the chain of
command will react
so it's kind of always kind of made me
think there was something to the
Rendlesham case because I sure as hell
wouldn't put up reports like that it
would be your ass you know I mean to put
up reports like that and the lead
officer in charge of that I think he's a
credible guy I think I think he did see
what he says that he saw now there's a
bunch of stuff surrounding that case
that we'll get into later
that you know on a case-by-case basis
but Jenny Jenny's done some good
investigation we're gonna try to we're
gonna try to we're gonna try to whittle
Rendlesham down into what most likely
happened in that period of time yeah you
know because I think there's some
variations in his story but we'll get to
that
yeah but yes so that so we decided to do
that for a Christmas special because
it's like paranormal UFO we don't do a
lot of UFO stories but we've had a lot
of people request particularly
Rendlesham forest and i said well it
happened around Christmas time the
warminster thing happened around
Christmas time so let's do that for our
Christmas special might do some other
you know we might talk about other
Christmas [ __ ] you know on a
case-by-case basis as we kind of think
of it but before we do that let me get a
little bit into a couple brief shoutouts
um
if you still want more Christmas stuff
from us and you haven't seen our last
movie retrospective we actually did a
Christmas movie double feature Christmas
evil which was from 1980 also called you
better watch out kind of a Christmas
slasher not really but kind of a horror
movie and then we also did the 2018
Netflix movie the Christmas Chronicles
starring it was a really good movie
flicks right now to Netflix original
it's a damn Spielberg and epic about
what would happen if Santa Claus was a
man nope Russell is a real man he's
playing playing Santa it's a super fun
that's a good movie I liked it we're
gonna watch it again yeah we're gonna
watch it again on Christmas Day I think
it is it is a it is a Christmas
masterpiece so yeah check that out if
you want more at Christmas it's like
what would happen if diehard was
actually a what else is it like also
have a couple of thank yous to send out
at this Christmas season I'd like to
thank you very much Melanie for your
very generous PayPal donation you rock
also we have a new heavy hitter patron
on our patreon page named cool kitty yep
so thank you very much you guys very
much appreciated especially this time of
year
I know everybody's everybody ances are
stretched pretty thin though ours are we
spent all our [ __ ] on presents yeah
pretty much yeah so you know it's like I
said it's way more appreciated this time
of year because we know what situation
most people are in so let's kind of talk
a little bit about this thing called the
warminster thing now the first thing I
have to say is it amuses me okay but
this whole thing is called the
warminster thing that's what they call
it the thing the warminster thing I
don't know anything about this she's
kind of told me a little I didn't either
until I searched yeah and some kind of
interested in here in this case and I'll
just ride along with the audience and if
I come up with some questions that's
probably similar to the kind of
questions the audience members might
have if you have a question just ask by
the time you see this look see if you're
watching this on Christmas Day we
recorded a couple days yeah Christmas
all right so the warminster thing there
um there's really no consensus on when
the phenomena actually started now it
didn't really start out necessarily as a
UFO phenomenon where is this weird one
it's in Wiltshire in South in the South
of England okay so this is another
English case just along with I love when
a theme comes together like that it's a
Christmas theme it's an English theme
it's those is a Christmas thing in the
UK I yeah well no in well it's friar
they have ghost stories yeah that's a
Christmas thing just messin with me
that's why I always kind of wanted to do
something around that too but it's
always hard for me to kind of cuz I love
Christmas ghost stories and I feel like
that's a tradition that's been lost over
the years but you know so there's this
little town called warminster now there
had been some kind of weird little
reports of you know lights in the sky
shut like that in the early 60s but most
reports you know most stories about the
warminster thing said that the main bulk
of it started on Christmas Day of 1964
like I said it didn't initially start
out as a UFO phenomena it initially
started out as an anomalous auto
to worry phenomena so Christmas Day of
1964 apparently there were a whole bunch
about 30 people in this town who
reported being woken up about five-ish
in the morning by a really really weird
noise now what some some of the people
described it as a droning some people
described it as sounding like like
leaves and twigs like a whole bunch of
leaves and twigs being dragged across
the rooftop some people described it
more of an explosion II type noise or
like a bunch of like a chimney
collapsing like a bunch of bricks
falling on the ground so a whole bunch
of people said that they heard this
particular sound on Christmas Day it was
during the daytime well it was very
early morning no one actually physically
saw anything no one saw anything not at
this stage and then there was not a
question now what's that they're saying
that they heard this who did they report
this to is this something that they
called the police about or is it
something that they that they that they
talked about in retrospect after this
case it is now that I'm not really sure
because like I said there had been a
couple of sporadic like rapport like you
more classic UFO style reports like
earlier than that there was something
like in 1961 and stuff so I'm not sure
if they reported it to the press at the
time and they reported it to the police
at the time so I'm tell you right now if
I was sitting in the house early in the
morning I heard something song leaves
blowing across the town or limbs going
across the the roof or I'm not gonna be
calling the cops over that so I just
wondering how they're how these effects
got put in with this case well I'm like
I said this case is very nebulous okay I
had never heard of it it doesn't seem to
be a big I mean I'm not saying like
apparently the Wiltshire area in England
is a big like UFO hotspot like there's
all these like hills and stuff and a lot
of like UFO Watchers will go and sit on
these hills and watch for them yeah and
apparently it has been for a while but
as I said no one was saying UFO at the
beginning they just said what the hell
are all these weird noises so then
evidently that same morning which was
Christmas morning little past 6:00 a.m.
apparently there's this woman her name
is Marjorie bye and she's walking to
church on Christmas morning and then she
hears these similar kind of noises like
just coming out of thin air and she
claimed that they were so loud and so
oppressive that they actually like
stopped her in her tracks and like made
her like not be able to walk further and
like it kind of like pressed down on her
type of thing so this is the type of
thing that was reported from Christmas
1964 onward for the next few months now
what did she say it sounded like she
didn't specify actually but like I said
most people said it either sounded like
now later on some of the people said
that maybe it sounded like a really
really loud droning sound but some
people said you know like I said it was
like a like a scraping like a really
loud scraping sound or like the sound of
a bunch of bricks hitting the ground
what that's all very different yeah but
that's you know yes so I don't want to
roll with it we're gonna roll yeah and
then I guarantee as this goes on people
what's happening as people witness
things that are more dramatic than this
probably what they're saying to the
interview is you know early that morning
I heard some you know yeah I think a lot
of that happens too because I think
sometimes you know and this cos kind of
goes with any sort of paranormal
phenomena but then a lot of people
witness or something like that
the minute that one person see something
weird or hear something weird even if
you yourself don't think of anything
like weird of it at the time if you hear
later reports of like oh I heard this
print then you're gonna associate it
with that even if it was nothing to do
with it so so these these sounds might
just be based upon like some kind of
like some psychological effects of
giving a report you know I mean like
yeah later on I saw some lights and and
then they asked they asked the person
did you hear anything strange earlier on
in the morning he's a
yeah yeah I did yeah all those like I
said really no one reported seeing
anything until many many months later
and this was like different people whoa
whoa okay okay so this weird why would
they remember these weird sounds at this
point okay I'm staying in that stage I'm
thinking probably since the two events
were so you know there's such a large
gap in time I'm assuming that the people
that heard these weird noises what did
report them to someone at the time okay
because otherwise it wasn't like the
same thing where oh we saw something in
the sky and then earlier today later no
it was no it was like six months okay
and then later investigators come in and
then they find out that there was a
weird there was a weird phenomena that
it happened two months before and then
they write that into the case but I can
see yeah so yeah that that could be true
also that like people went back and said
oh all these people heard these weird
noises six months ago and maybe that's
related missing so they might be
relating to things that are not related
okay so evidently six months later June
1965 there was a family and they were in
a little town near warminster they and
17 other people saw a bright glowing
cigar shaped object in the sky just your
standard UFO they saw this bowl everyone
was out fishing at the lake or what
happy so a lot of people saw this so 17
people team yeah were they all in the
same area do they know where this yeah
it seemed like they were all like
fishing and swimming like in this like
watering hole or like by a lake or
something so they said that they all saw
like a cigar-shaped thing now a couple
months after that in August of 1965 in
the middle of the night it was about
3:45 in the morning another woman in
Warminster was awakened by another
strange sound as she she said that it
sounded like a really really loud
droning and that she went to the window
and looked out and saw a really really
bright object in the sky that looked
like it could have been a star but much
much bigger and brighter
perhaps the cigar shaped object that
they saw did it would they see what
color it was just just glowing glowing
yeah no descriptions on the size or if
it was moving
I think maybe later on some people
described it because I think later on
some people saw one like hovering over
rode and said it was orange and then I
think another woman later on described a
different one as like being as big as
her bedroom wall like you know what I
mean but she was seeing it from far away
but it was as big as her bedroom wall
like that sound she was the same thing
like a vapor trail with light shining
off of it you know I mean during well
yeah Dusk's you know during sundown
alright so okay now at this stage you
know that is so far so fairly standard
yeah there's weird noises yeah people
are seeing UFOs in the sky and maybe
these things are related maybe it's some
kind of paranormal activity maybe it's
something else
warminster is actually close to a Royal
Air Force Base so people were saying you
know maybe that had something to do with
it maybe was experimental aircraft or
what have you but really the story
didn't take off until this dude named
Arthur shuttle would comes along now at
the time that all of this phenomena was
going on he was actually just a
journalist for the local paper so he was
just sent there to kind of report on the
story because it was an interesting you
know local story however as the years
went on he got much more involved in
these and that he ended up writing a
couple books about the warminster thing
and going completely off into cloud
cuckoo-land you know what I'm saying
like all like he's talking about like
talking to aliens and they came to his
house to visit him and all this other
kind of stuff so this guy it seems like
he started out just like oh I'm gonna go
cover this crazy local interest story
but all these people that claim they've
seen you if I was or heard these weird
noises and then he decides I don't know
if he just like went crazy like you know
naturally or if he just decided hey I'm
gonna make some money off this catching
and I'm just gonna like come up with the
crazy ship that his finances that's what
I mean now he's passed away at this
point he Pat he died in 1996 but so the
thing is though there was so much
interest about what they already were
starting to call the warminster thing
because they didn't know if it was a UFO
they didn't know what it was because
like I said the sounds and the sightings
they didn't know if they were
related so that's just what everyone
called it the warminster thing so
because there was a Royal Air Force Base
nearby because peeps some people thought
it was alien some people thought it was
you know experimental aircraft or
whatever there was a lot of interest in
it in the town and like a lot of people
around in the area that were kind of
into UFOs and stuff started like mobbing
the tower and like coming and sitting on
up on all the hills like to see if they
could see anything and all all this
other kind of stuff now actually local
officials were interested enough in it
that they decided that they were gonna
have like a town-hall meeting and they
were gonna like put it on TV and
everything so that everybody could like
discuss it and like they could talk
about what it was and [ __ ] like that so
we're gonna put it on national
television in August of that's weird
because yeah it's so nebulous and the
differences you know I mean each report
seems to be widely separated from the
other ones yeah that's what I just call
it the thing yeah it's just a weird
phenomena that this happened sounds
almost kind of like I hate to use the
word mass hysteria
not really sounds like it has been
speculated that it could be master
because it does have some of that some
of that aspect to it yeah you know what
I mean I think it might be where it is
the beginning of a local culture yeah of
kind of reporting and looking for weird
things maybe because other people saw it
it could be because you know mad gasser
that time yeah that's what I was
thinking too and it should be noted too
that this particular area of Wiltshire
is very rich in folkloric history like a
lot of the like hills around there we're
supposed to be you know you know like
druids or the devil built it or
something like there's like a lot of
folklore and legends around this area so
it might just be that people are just
modernizing you know folklore from the
area to kind of be more alien centric
the British have this thing that they
that they call taking the piss well
taking the piss means [ __ ] with you
just taking the piss we'll see we'll see
well now one guy that's actually a good
segue because we got this who definitely
was taking the piss okay was this guy
named David Halton now he lived around
there and he decided what he was gonna
do he was gonna show up at this
town-hall meeting now he had been
telling people around the town that the
weird noises in the sky had actually
been
killing pigeons like he was finding like
all these dead pigeon bodies everywhere
and it was the sound was doing it's like
the UFO was really killing his pigeons
so he had kind of started spreading that
story around and he also said that he
had like a big file with like a bunch of
sightings of UFOs and photos and photos
of the dead pigeons and everything like
that so so he did have some evidence
well he said he did but see that's the
thing he's like so everyone all the
towns folks were like well hey why don't
you bring it to this convenient town
hall meeting he's like oh yeah well I'd
love to do that but I don't really think
that's the right venue yeah to be
showing this kind of you know sort of
values the right venue so the thing
about it is that so
sometimes like um because I read a bunch
of different accounts of the warminster
thing and they're kind of wildly all
over the map it's kind of hard to
determine what actually happened and
when but a lot of them do have the
detail of like oh this out the sounds
were so loud that it killed pigeons but
evidently this part was completely
fabricated um that guy actually never
showed any evidence of that and in 2005
he actually told the newspaper that yeah
I just made that up just for shits and
giggles now you do find thoughts of
Dead's birds sometimes but there's
always an explanation well yeah the
flock of birds gets involved with some
boys and it was up on a rooftop
that's one yeah another one sometimes
you'll find a bunch of them dead on the
ground usually underneath a light in a
parking lot it's because when they're
flying in certain lighting conditions at
night if there's a little thin sheet of
water on them on the ground the
reflections of the of the parking lot
lamps make it look like there's a deep
enough body of water to land in and that
whole flock comes in for a landing and
the one the lead bird splats right there
on that look on the concrete and the
other ones can't they can't stop in time
so they all just concrete terrible yeah
and then afterwards you know
when the morning comes people are like
yeah you didn't you weren't you didn't
have the point of view of the birds
trying to come in for a landing well you
think that people wouldn't think it was
that strange because I mean if you have
reflective windows on your office
building as I know hit that an office
building I used to work in did we had
[ __ ] birds hitting that every single
goddamn just whack yeah
and that's what's happening with the
ground that either they think the waters
deeper than it is or they miss calculate
the distance to the surface that's
another thing yeah just like the same
way they run they don't see glass you
don't see the glass fly through it or
it's a it's reflective yeah like a
mirror and they think they can go
through it
it's that same effect well yeah that's
wet concrete kills lots of birds under a
certain lighting conditions I mean I can
see how you be freaked out like coming
out of your house and there's like all
these dead birds oh yeah yeah that
because usually after a storm yeah
sometimes they associated with the storm
they think well they must got struck by
lightning in the sky and they all came
down or I was some lightning herd before
it was really properly explained to me
they got caught up in a tornado and they
all you know I got deposited they got
blown in circles and I got killed and
they were all deposited in the same area
not happened know if you were seeing
that but from the point of view of the
birds it would make perfect sense out
and they were trying to land on what
they thought was a thick body of water
although I feel like if you're kind of
already in clients who believe in
paranormal things and you actually did
witness like a bunch of birds just
flying into the ground yeah you would
probably attribute that's a paranormal
causes to instead of just them not being
able to see the judge the distance yeah
that's right
Birds mess up just like people yeah even
though there are a lot smarter than some
people I know but they still do mess up
every now I don't want the only ones
like these guttin the only cases like
these that kind of sometimes make me
wonder is when they find big deposits of
fish yeah what dead fish and someone was
slight he's kicking still just on the
ground yeah you know I read a couple
cases like that during storms yeah they
thought maybe they were picked up by
waterspout yeah but they would be strewn
everywhere they wouldn't all fall in one
spot I think it's
more likely they were in a big barrel or
a bucket in the back of a truck maybe
they were gonna go stock up or in a
plane weren't applying something they
were frozen I don't know a lot of times
they're still kicking yeah a father I
don't know that's weird but here okay if
somebody just made those stories up well
yes you always have to you have to keep
that possibility I saw some photographs
of it but it was in one of those like
mysteries you not explained type books
yeah and that's kind of their bread
muttered yeah you see a bunch of fish on
the ground but you don't have the
context you know I mean like just buy
some fish and throw them on the ground
or you know no oh that's a good idea we
should yeah 500 fish thought on the
ground ago yeah waterspout brought him
here so now right here this is my
actually absolute favorite part of this
story so remember I told you about this
arthur shuttle would fella that was like
a journalist a local journalist and he
was the one that started you know
writing about the warminster thing and
then later went right off the rails
before he wrote a couple of books about
it okay now this is what he claims he
claims that on that on September 26th of
1965 he says someone called him and this
person that called him said they were
from another planet okay yeah call him
on the phone no cousin no cuz then no he
was in town I was in town yeah he said
that he was from a planet called and I'm
not sure if I'm pronouncing this
correctly but things like that you see
it's right here in my notes a est si he
said that was the name of the planet and
yeah so he says the the alien the
alleged alien or the other in his phone
says that his name is carne and on it
right was she like incarnate okay okay
and maybe it's carne I'm not sure but it
looks if it's spelled like chili con
carne I said with except for the K so
evidently Arthur who was no dummy asked
this caller you know you have to prove
that you're really from another planet
you can't fool me that easily you got
you come over so I can have a look at
you yeah and then he says only a couple
seconds later yeah someone knocks at his
door he opens the door and he's like and
there's he didn't really describe him
almost like I haven't read his book I
just kind of read a summary of it he
says he was kind of like a funny-looking
dude he just didn't have any pupils in
his eyes like he had like the you know
yeah I guess and then that his
cheekbones and lips had like blue
blotches on them okay
so apparently the alien spends about
nine or ten minutes in Arthur's house
and that you know as aliens at the time
were want to do you know said you need
to stop with all these nuclear weapons
and stuff because there's gonna be a
World War three at some point in the
future which actually was pretty smart
because if Arthur Schiller would made
this up he could have said oh there's
gonna be a wars in 1999 or whenever like
the predictions we're back then but he
just said oh it'll be in the future so
you know he's covering all the bases
right there everybody yeah so um you
know so he said oh there's gonna be a
war in the Middle East this is
Nostradamus [ __ ] and then evidently
we've got not enough to Thomas yeah we
need to show I know which I I can't
believe we haven't done an ostrich yeah
you know we did one about end of the
world prediction it's all in the
interpretation of the quadrant you ride
enough stuff and you interpret well
enough you can get a quatrain to fulfill
just about anything yeah well that's
kind of that whole yeah well every
psychic in the world you know psychic
with bunny rabbit ears as any his art
says is they know that your stock and
trade is vagueness yeah reading tea
leaves literally you have to be very
very vague about when and where it's
gonna happen otherwise you're gonna be
so nice chops off you're gonna have a
bad time some of that stuff sounds
really close but yeah but like I said
you're reading like a translation of a
translation of the translation which
might not even have been the Carrera
modernize exactly so they're you know
people are in massage
things after the fact to kind of sound
like it fits in with you know what I
mean because we already know that should
happen so it's easy to kind of be this
that's totally what he meant being an
alchemist and a soothsayer and a seer
you know that was a gig back in the day
well yeah like everything yeah it's just
like the gig economy nowadays but you
know back then you're just like you had
to tell really good futures yeah and
like I said the way you did that and you
learned it pretty quick I imagine
especially back in those days where you
might get your ass beheaded if you like
[ __ ] something up is like you really
have to kind of keep it sort of keep it
positive all I keep it big I think I
think a big part of it also was you had
to really know how to entertain the
nobility so I think entertainment was a
big factor well yeah you gotta they
didn't have like you know movies and
xbox back then it's like you know what I
mean somebody just had to come over and
like tell you Joe for something yeah
existence didn't have any presence or
anything right well they didn't know any
better I guess if you had [ __ ] tons of
money I'm sure it was fine yeah but yeah
so Arthur also said that this alleged
alien kid chilli con carne yeah um that
he was having difficulty breathing that
he had so perhaps this was a form that
he had taken on when he came to earth
and he wasn't quite you know maybe it
was kind of itchy ER didn't fit right
the human suit I'm not really sure so
yeah so apparently so he says he goes to
shake his hand and like the alien was
like ah that hurt so bad and then he
like wanders offering yeah okay so
whenever I hear these accounts whenever
I hear these accounts of like a 1950
style contact between humans and aliens
I'm already calling [ __ ] I mean
carne that is such yeah that is such a
Roger Corman
alien movie name isn't it I mean what
they all had K names didn't they clot
you and you all had names like that no
it really is what Hayes or X's real air
aliens wouldn't give a [ __ ] about us or
what we were doing see I always wondered
about them only why the [ __ ] would they
come here it's like I'm sure they could
like maybe they scoot by and like check
it's like good are they gonna blow
they're not gonna come here and give us
man technology they're not gonna come
here and try to solve our problems
they're not gonna come here and try to
stop nuclear weapons because that's none
of their business they don't care about
it
I mean we're not gonna fly to other
planets to stop and cavemen from making
fire
you know because aliens wouldn't don't
care about nuclear weapons they're like
oh yeah those old things some of those
my matches yeah yeah match that's what I
always thought to see I think that a lot
of the UFO thing it's like people that
are being really human-centric
and you think because we think other
humans are interesting or we think
ourselves are interested then yeah you
would assume that someone for another
planet would think we were interesting I
have I have no such be like me go out
backyard and find a pile of hands yeah
good and I'm not gonna go to hands go
take me to your leader I'm gonna give
you some matter how awesome would that
be if you do and they did yeah I'm gonna
give you some maps they shrunk you down
and then you went down in the who's in
charge here happen that way hey I'm just
watch TV the internet you know you know
you're just gonna walk by them you're
not gonna notice them yeah and that's
any kind of interstellar type traveling
any any kind of civilization that can
travel interstellar the distances
involved is probably no longer
biological it's gonna be more like
something out of 2001 when you think if
they were gonna come back I feel like
we're not machines I feel like we're not
interesting and enough to justify coming
that far
well you're wrong they're just running
around doing their own business and
unless yeah they don't care unless like
you said I think I think your your
analogy of like a park ranger it was a
really good analogy if indeed there are
extraterrestrials flying around every
now and then and people do have seen
them on occasion perhaps then I think
that is the most likely scenario that
they're just like they're little cops or
Park Rangers and they're just checking
out the outside of their little town I'm
not buying it that these are biological
entities that what we know about
technology and how things are evolving
I'm not gonna buy that anymore they're
gonna be living machines with godlike
intelligence and they're living inside
of an Internet in their own mind
interconnected with the other ones they
don't have physical bodies they are that
spaceship and then they they control
robots and
though their little crafts they're uh
they're kind of like a technological
awareness or a technological being that
exists inside of its own Internet you
know what I mean yeah and it controls
crafts that go around to monitor our
reality but they're not really a part of
it in the same way we are I think
they're mostly inside of an Internet
which would be like I haven't us yeah so
you could might save these or angels or
these are gods and they're probably
immortal there because they're not
carrying on biology which means that
that would mean you wouldn't need to go
fast so so what it takes a million years
oh I got a plenty of time they don't die
yeah it's like [ __ ] I'm just gonna get
in this car yeah I would think they'd be
something like like the the monolith out
of 2001 yeah that's that's probably what
you're dealing with yeah I I agree with
you God like non-biological yeah an
entity that's almost kind of like a
group universal consciousness inside of
the like its own weird internet in its
own mind doing things here they see us
they don't even really notice us yeah
like I walk outside I don't notice all
these blades of grass you know yeah
we're just part of the environment
that's what I think yeah I would agree
with you there God back there go back
there and see a wasp nests you know I
don't go home an alien civilization look
what they can build you know I'm so
impressive these little boys I just
spray them yeah that way and that's
funny because watch to them it's like
that's probably like a big alien
invasion it's like oh [ __ ] cuz it's like
they built this whole little thing and
now you're just coming on going if you
didn't do that I'd leave you alone yeah
I'm just I don't kill bugs willy-nilly
but I don't like them like there might
be there might be some living creatures
out there that are at the same level of
us but their chances are gonna be very
very far away yeah we probably be able
to ever contact them and if they were at
our level they would be dangerous
because work dangerous so they'd be
dangerous too we wouldn't get along with
them
probably not if there were anywhere near
our level probably because there's gonna
be a bunch of overlapping interests and
we're gonna start competing like any
other species in nature starts competing
edges and they start fighting yeah so
there's probably stuff at our level it's
just that it's gonna be real far away
unlikely you ever see it thank God not
really you know yeah you think we're bad
to each other imagine how bad they'd be
to us or we be to them you know it'd be
something bad yeah it'd probably be like
something out of a lien yeah so anyways
after a carne allegedly popped around to
earth or shuttle woods
please personalty or whatever um over
the next couple of months there were a
bunch very very odd reports in the same
town evidently several different people
driving along various stretches of road
kept reporting that they saw people some
of them were grayish some of them were
naked one of them was naked except it's
just a jacket which seems a little weird
some of the people reported that they
had hit these whatever they were with
their car and you know actually felt the
car go over them but then like when they
stopped and went back the body was gone
some other people reported seeing people
that looked kind of frog-like and they
were like leaping around or like leaping
into hedges and whatnot so for like a
couple months that year like in October
in November in 1965 there were several
reports of that type of thing which that
really sounds like a mad gasser of
Mattoon type of situation where you know
you hear one report hey yeah I hit this
gray guy that looked like and then when
I went back and the body was gone it was
like it looked like a frog it's like you
know what I mean so there was a whole
bunch of that that went on I think until
about January and then there was about
maybe like a year where there wasn't
really that many reports it seems to
have died down a little bit and then
there came more UFO reports I was one
person in January of 1967 this old guy
reported that he saw a UFO hovering
above the field now he also said that he
saw two aliens with helmets get out of
it
and wonderful I always wondered about
because I said now this is what this is
what kills him like why don't we ever
see like people report like a UFO and it
landed and the aliens that got out
looked like little jello cubes
yeah they know they always look look
like a centipede yeah they always look
humanoid pretty much I mean it's really
only the last few years in sci-fi that
and pretty much now ever since alien you
know a lot of the aliens would look like
big insects or something like that which
is probably more likely than human I
think more likely but um you know they
never look like anything other than that
it seems like except the blob which Wow
now that I'm thinking about that's
really original yeah like just a blob
from outer space he looked like a big
[ __ ] Slurpee well they're just
talking about what the blob they're
talking about the amoeba basically is
what they're talking about but that's
pretty much the only one you saw what
would that be a pretty accurate you
would think that yeah that could be
alien just like a big immediate big
amoeba yeah I like this stuff wait was
that an alien or was that I can't
remember somebody made yeah that might
have been like a industrial accident I
can't remind that maybe a long time
although it is on shudders I practically
rewatch it yeah so like I said this area
of Wiltshire has a lot of kind of
druidic legends around it and all the
hills and everything but you know over
the next few years from like 1967
through like the early 1970s the town
kind of became like I said like a UFO
hotspot so like all these people you
know little Inns would open up and
they'd have like all these tourists
coming in and like sitting up on these
hills like looking for aliens and all
this other stuff now evidently later on
this Arthur shuttle would guy who was
supposedly got the visit from Carney he
actually went to his death like never
wavering in his alien story and he he
pretty much became something of a
messiah figure it seems like in UFO
circles in that area like he was very
well respected and he
you know kept seeing visions of you know
supposedly kept seeing visions of aliens
like they come in his room and stuff you
know your classic alien abduction kind
of see the faux scene has changed a lot
over the generations you know I mean
yeah a lot of this stuff really when you
when you really analyze what it is
they're talking about has a very
religious quality to it yeah you know
and a couple of things I read about this
like pointed out oh yeah it's almost
kind of like a pseudo religious cult and
they actually have religious cults like
Heaven's Gate and everything you know
yeah where there's a price yeah and in a
way you could say that Scientology is a
UFO cult it is exactly that yeah because
it's basically it's like a religion but
it also has sci-fi like corporate sci-fi
element row is basically what it is I
think the corporate thing was new and
that's all going away if you asked me
when you when you talk to young people
who are wondering and when you talk to
young people who discuss UFOs or in the
UFO ding it sounds a little a lot more
plausible than it used to
yeah they're thrown out the bad cases
and focusing more on just like sightings
that Air Force pilots had you cops know
there's some of them that cops had you
know what I mean that were there were
two or three police stations what was
that thing called the triangle over
Illinois
yeah Illinois case we're gonna show
about that yeah they did see that
yeah just whether or not that was
extraterrestrial I think it might have
been some kind of stealth Zeppelin small
stealth lamp see I always kind of leaned
something like that I'm not saying that
like everybody that sees stuff like that
didn't see anything I just don't
necessarily I mean whether it was in a
one-dog that creature oh that's a
different question he got a picture of
it all you could see was the the lights
at the corner at the corners and it was
all screwed up but I know that these
they saw it you could hear you hear the
radio traffic between all the police
units that were seeing it just said they
didn't know what it was yeah well this
guy sure but you know yeah that's the
thing and I feel like well plus two
we've had you know all the science
popularization and stuff like look at
like Neil deGrasse Tyson and people and
you know Carl Sagan before that you know
shows like cosmos and stuff so people
know how science works more than they
did in the 1950s maybe if
you see sci-fi movies from the 1950s the
ridiculous yeah and like people just
like okay yeah roll with it that's how
science works but not it's like you know
like one and I bring this up a lot it's
not necessarily like science fiction or
alien related but there was one I think
it was a colossal man or something like
that someone with Glenn Manning where he
grows like two really big size for
radiation and actually a doctor in that
movie well he's an actor playing a
doctor says that the heart is one big
cell ridiculous and like no one calls
mine it's like what the [ __ ] where did
you get your medical degree yeah you
know what I mean that's those days you
could just say anything yes you could
just school and plus those were marketed
to our children and they knew children
didn't we're stupid and now they're just
like whatever just make it up as you
went along but you think that the people
that made it would at least go yeah we
can't say that I mean or at least just
cut that line out I guess not it's like
as much as people talk about the good
old days like I said really just very
happy yeah we're talking about you know
our planets a hundred million miles away
that's pretty close yeah relatively
better thousand mile one hundred million
miles away or two million miles away
[ __ ] that's not even boner right that's
right past them oh yeah whoa wow that's
super far they never even mentioned a
Lightyear yeah well it was the people
right in this green list they didn't
know where they didn't care they just
threw that [ __ ] together in like a week
or two and soon Roger Corman's like we
have three movies to shoot this week
yeah I don't even give a [ __ ] but yeah
so that was pretty much the bulk of it
there were there actually have been
strange sightings like up until then
there were a few weird ones like in 1972
somebody saw another disc shaped object
this time they described it as orange
they said that shortly after this they
saw a very very tall figure with white
clothing on that kind of like ran along
the road like in very strange in a very
strange way apparently this same being
or one like it was seen a little while
later like a couple months later by a
different person he was driving along
the same road same thing had white
clothes was jumping over bushes and
stuff and you know this actually this
woman that had the second sighting that
said that she saw this creepy
and she said she saw it and it scared
her so she like booked at home and then
she said a couple hours later she was
sleeping and then like a 5 in the
morning somebody rang her doorbell and
she got up to answer the door there was
nobody there but yeah so other than that
like I said to this day you know it's
still kind of even though it's not as
well known I mean obviously not as well
known as Rendlesham forest because
everybody knows about that one I had
actually never I'm not a big UFO buff
but I had never heard of this and it
didn't seem like there was a ton of
information about it actually the town
of warminster a few years back they
commissioned like a mural like on this
wall in the town of like all these
little aliens and stuff it's pretty cute
I'll put a picture of it in the video
but so it's still a place that a lot of
people go and to this day no one has you
know obviously UFO sightings blah blah
blah but no one has really explained
what the noises were like what that
whole thing was that started out the
whole warminster thing which like I said
just started out as an auditory
phenomena so I really haven't seen any
explanations of what that might have
been if it was indeed real if people did
actually hear that me it sounds like a
couple of UFO hoaxes yeah over Ninh with
some weird reports of some weird sounds
yeah it does seem like one of those
things where you know maybe there were a
couple of anomalous incidents and like I
said I think I was talking about this a
little bit our mad gasser of Mattoon and
Spring Heeled Jack show where I was
saying you know maybe there was like one
or two strangers like maybe I heard like
a really weird noise and I don't know
what the hell it was and then later on
said oh I saw a light in this guy and I
knew what it was and people like
conflated those two things and it became
this big quote-unquote thing and it
became this whole thing but I just
thought it was interesting like I said I
think it was more of a statistical
anomaly yeah it's a bunch of reports of
different kinds of things happening in
this area over its certain period of
time and some investigators later on
went and try to weave all that together
into one phenomenon yeah that's what I
think it was it does definitely sound
like that and it sounds like a lot of
the mythology surrounding it came
from that guy's books you know he wrote
a book called I think it was called the
warminster mystery and I think you
brought one called in alien heat like a
porn movie that's yeah that's what I was
thinking I was like really the title of
it I don't know if I want to read that
I'm gonna see that I think that was the
name of it and I was just like yeah that
sounds like one of those weird alien
erotica books not that I've read any of
those but of all those tentacles
Japanese girls I don't think that is it
does not aliens though it's more like a
Cthulhu type thing and aren't they like
from those yeah alright so before we go
to the break since it's a Christmas show
why don't we talking about some
Christmas [ __ ] like what do you remember
what the best Christmas present you ever
got was or what your best Christmas was
or a Christmas tradition that your
family did that you enjoyed that you
miss something like that can you think
of anything yeah okay I think probably
the best Christmas present I ever got
was when I was a little kid and I got
that one of those right up there oh one
of the you can't see if I can't see it
right there it's great mazinger show the
warrior love that I got two of them
sitting up there one of them isn't
finished though in the 1970s big ol
robot we and so little Tom like open it
up and you were like actually I think it
was already open my dad had opened it up
set it up on top of the bar you know my
dad he knew he was he'd probably play
with that [ __ ] before he gave to me
let's see how cool big ol Shogun
warriors were quite different from
everything else that was around at that
time yeah yeah and they were kind of I
always thought that kind of had these
weird demonic look to them they do kind
of red blue I mean you have a bunch of
them faces there in your like up on top
of my bookshelves and stuff they're like
little robots oh I love Japanese robots
yeah he does he's got like I should go
in the guy robots people haven't they
don't know what these are
yeah yeah they do don't don't assume
that look people don't know
I like Mazinger great mazinger
robo the thief yeah I think the Jenny
the getter robo theme song is probably
my favorite band eyes or UFO yeah yeah
but they have really good theme songs I
can't remember if this was a Christmas
present or not but I remember receiving
the and we were just talking about
weebles just now I'm not gonna say in
what context but I received the Weeble
haunted mansion and it was this open
remember that thing yeah it opened like
a dollhouse and it was like it was all
[ __ ] like the front door open and
closed and it creaked and it came with
like a little furniture like a little
couch and like little stuff you could
put in there it came with a little witch
with the little plastic hat that snapped
on it came with a little ghost that
glowed in the dark
and it came with two little kid weebles
who had the most hilarious like
horrified expressions on their faces
they looked like oh like that like never
scared and it was like a there was like
a thing you could attach to the back the
attached look to the chimney and it was
like a secret passage and type of thing
oh my god I loved that [ __ ] thing I
wish I still had it actually my mom I
asked her about it she said it was
probably in my attic somewhere but I
don't think she ever found it I did find
the witch weeble but I can't find her
hat anywhere so I still have the witch
weevil somewhere but that was probably I
don't remember I think I got that for
Christmas that's probably my favorite
Christmas present and I can you know
what I kind of miss um we used to do you
know my grandmother on my father's side
we always had Christmas Eve at her house
and she always put up her little tree
that was on top of this very very 70s
like table that was made of latex strips
of wood and it was painted like avocado
green or something so she put the tree
on top of that and she always like went
all out she bought every because you
know I have a bunch of cousins and stuff
and she bought everybody like tons and
tons of presents and she always would
wrap them and put them all out like
weeks ahead of time so the day when she
put all the presents out under the tree
like all the kids would be at the house
like and then we like all be like look
and runs like which ones for me this was
for you
you and it was like it was so cool and
like they sat there the whole time just
like taunting you because you weren't
able to open them and then so on
Christmas Eve the whole family would
come over and then the adults knew that
the kids wanted to open the presents but
they would not let you open the presents
till everyone was done eating and they
would take forever on purpose so they
just like be sitting over there the
table go on and I have some more ham I'm
gonna have some more the kids are like
come on you [ __ ] no we're just
like over there sitting next to this is
like like waiting to dive into this big
pile of presents and I really really
I've missed that cuz my grandma died
many years ago but um you know when to
even them she was like too sick to do it
for a couple years before that but
that's one thing that I always remember
we always did that on Christmas Eve so
it's funny because I'm always like more
excited about Christmas Eve and
Christmas Day because Christmas Eve that
was the big thing that was open at all
grandma's presents and then like the
next day we each could or iron houses
and like you know it was cool open and
stuff from your parents too but then it
was over you know what I mean there was
a lot more build-up and a lot more
excitement like for Christmas Eve so I
was kind of looking I was looking I was
I was an only child so I got all the
Christmas present yeah see I have three
siblings me all kinds of stuff and then
they give me like one time I got
hamsters got two hamsters and a half how
long did they live look a long time okay
that's good I had a hamster it ate all
its babies and then a dog no they lasted
a while you know they get sick they get
fevers and then they died yeah they
don't live but a little while I was
taking those hamsters I remember I had
pictures of them for that Christmas
that's probably out five I was taking
those hamsters and rapid tinfoil all
over them they can run there my dog was
tripping whoa what are those things she
need him she was cool with him she's
just like yeah yeah she tried to pick
him up though space hamster
try to pick them up yeah
you know don't read that yeah yeah yeah
a lot of dogs will eat hamsters you
can't trust him with them but you know
my dog wasn't mean she was I think she's
trying to pick him up and play with him
yeah you know it's a little fuzzy moving
back when we have tinsel on trees well
it's just a mess you don't want Ansel
well and also it's not good cuz we have
cats and it's real Astro to eat it's
really not good to put tinsel on your
trees if you have pets I don't know if
you guys know that because if you eat it
it's really they eat it and it'll like
ball up and they get that stuck in their
little yeah
streamers it's bad our cat is already
she's been mostly good she hasn't
climbed the Christmas tree that I know
of unless she did it in the middle of
the night
she did however at Christmas balls I
knock a Christmas ball off and then she
jumped on it and it broke yeah because
see the we had like glass what she looks
like they break yeah they right oh yeah
well because all the ones on the bottom
of the tree are plastic because she
hadn't been climbing the trees so like
all the glass would lay ceramic ones are
like high up on the thing but she's down
low but she got up to the jumped on it
no I was there I saw that how you jumped
on it and it broke and she looked at me
like woah where'd it go
and I said you broke it and I started
picking it up and she's looking looking
at the pieces you know she just kept
looking like they break I didn't know
that they broke she's a trip she is
she's hilarious
she's pretty it been pretty good she's
actually mostly just been sleeping under
the tree yeah um we wrapped all the
presents and put them under the tree
even though I was scared to because I
said she was just gonna tear the [ __ ]
cuz she loves paper and she loves to eat
paper um and you know I put a present
for her into the tree it's big and it
has like toys in it that smell like
catnip so I'm sure like the the package
smells like catnip so I thought she's
probably gonna like climb in that and
just like tear up and put all the paper
but she would sleep underneath there
with packages so unless she's doing
stuff in the middle of the night which
I'm sure she does cuz every now and then
I'll wake up in here I'm not worried
about her or she you know she goes in
the bathroom and like knocks stuff off
the yeah
so that's the thing it's like people
could break in our house and like we it
wouldn't even register cuz I'd wake up
and hear a noise and go baby cookie
that's not true
I've heard strange strange [ __ ] at night
remember yeah that's true yeah I jump up
out of bed the weirdest thing I heard
well we heard the garage door opening I
heard the doorbell ring no times yeah it
was like 3:30 4:00 in the morning I
heard some noises I thought it was a
voice but I think it was just think was
Beijing Beijing and baby cookie growling
at each other yeah well Beijing well
when it's the middle of the night I
guess she gets lonely yeah so she comes
into my office and grabs little toys off
the you know like my little Nightmare
Before Christmas stories and so on and
then goes like really loud throughout
the house like look I brought you a baby
get up about time for a break though
yeah we should probably take a break and
then when we come back we will talk
about another British Christmas alleged
UFO sighting yeah this is the best very
famous Rendlesham forest incident so we
will be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
and we're back on this extra-special
Christmas special edition of the 13
o'clock podcast we've got all our little
Santa's in the background plus buddy
Christ got our Christmas spirits in the
form of I got a I got a screwdriver and
you got a yeah yeah we should probably
got like some more seasonal I was gonna
get some hot chocolate and put some
drink all the eggnog you did yeah I had
so much yeah I don't like eggnog I know
that's like terrible but yeah he's he
had eggnog with Rome anybody drank it
all already like I said we started
celebrating early we already had a
turkey and everything alright so this
second Christmas era British alleged UFO
sighting is the very very famous
Rendlesham forest incident yeah now by
UFO enthusiasts this is usually put
forward as one of the most credible UFO
sightings ever in the world although I
have to say that the more I researched
it start start to fall apart more
skeptical I'm right and I was pretty
skeptical to start with but see because
it turns out that a lot of the kind of
iconic details of this thing that kind
of got repeated over and over like on
various documentaries you know later on
are not really what was reported at the
time they're not part of the original
case it seemed like a lot of stuff got
exaggerated later on by people that were
there so but first let's kind of go into
you know the pretty standard narrative
of what happened on this particular it
was actually over most of you say over
three nights but it was actually two
nights like separated by a night where
nothing happened
so it's December 25th the night of
December 25th 1980 in England there were
two bases RAF Woodbridge and RAF
Bentwaters and these were staffed by US
military now at the time it was kind of
a big secret that this was like a
nuclear installation I think it's still
sort of a secret
but I think it's more of a yeah really
was supposed to be there it was kind of
a violation yeah exactly
so I think it's supposed to have any
clear weapons within their boundaries as
far as I understand during during that
Cold War treaty but both sides were
violating yeah it was just part of the
part of the Cold War yeah so like I said
she get away with it yeah I still think
they don't really admit that there were
nuclear weapons there but I think most
people are like yeah we knew they
weren't missiles they were air they were
their bombs basically yeah so in between
these two these are called the twin
bases and there's about two miles in
between these and in between these there
is a forest called Rendlesham forest
so it's Christmas night there's this kid
he's 20 years old he's a patrol sergeant
named John Burroughs and it was his job
on Christmas night to guard the east
gate at RAF Woodbridge now shortly after
midnight um you know or you know once
the 25th had gone into the 26th he
starts seeing unusual colored lights
appearing through the trees they look
like they were maybe hovering or like
moving around I believe at first he
thought it was maybe a downed aircraft
so he thought that probably someone
should do something about that like to
check that out so what do we have any
information about how many times he's
served on this gate was this his first
night on I never read that anywhere a
lot of time you don't know how the Air
Force has a set up but a lot of times
these kind of duties are kind of handed
out over a rotation yeah you might have
to do it once a year right do it once
every two years of your deployment there
you don't know yeah I think these guys
actually think the air for Air Force has
a specially-trained security force that
always does security right you know I'm
talking about that's their job yeah I
don't know how often they're deployed to
gates and the guard posts I don't know I
don't really have those details do you
did you find anything about no they
actually they said that the one of the
other guys Jim Penniston that he had
actually served on this particular base
for two years but I don't know about the
other guy
just makes you wonder how used how used
to this duty were they I mean how was
this something they had been doing
they've been pulling this Duty for weeks
on end years on end is this their normal
job or they just tasked out because I
used to get tasked out in the army a lot
like one night I just guarded Tomahawk
missiles yeah not all Hellfire missiles
yeah I don't know about garden Hellfire
missiles like a guard thanks actually
they were in a an 18-wheel truck we had
stashed out in the back forty nobody
knew where it was that me and the guys
that put it there yeah cuz it was
millions of dollars where the Hellfire
missiles for the age sixty fours
yeah and you know it wasn't my normal
job first of all you're just around but
that job is the same no matter where you
are well yeah it so you're guarding
something yes make sure nothing happens
is that what happens then call somebody
but honest it in a situation like that
if I was there and I noticed that there
was a light shining through the trees I
would probably report it yeah but if I
work there every night for weeks on in
and I said well that's always those
lights are always there then I know that
that's not an unusual situation I'm
looking at something that's on the
ground and I'm just seeing it through
the trees
yeah which that could have been what
this guy is reporting see you're trying
to get down the one-state yeah like this
guy's seen a light that's normally there
and he's thinking that maybe it's
strange ortus or is he seeing a light
there for the very first time and he's
worked there for years we don't know
right I don't yeah I don't know about
that guy particularly okay he thought it
was odd enough that he went and reported
it to the security policemen on the base
whose name was Jim Penniston now as I
said Jim very much Jim Penniston had
worked there for two years now Jim
Penniston said that he had never seen
these particularly in the woods before
however he so like you know I mean I'm
just saying I'm not you know I'm not
calling him a liar the same right so he
decides you yeah we should he and he was
like yeah it's probably maybe it's a
downplaying or something like that they
didn't think UFO or anything like that
from you know initial reports I don't
think they thought it was a UFO they
this is a plane crashing I'm just
bringing this up for the
audience to let them know there's a good
chance that these guys doing these jobs
pulling these pulling this security job
maybe they've never actually done that
job in this location before yes and they
weren't really sure what lights were
supposed to be where well sir this may
not have been anything unusual this
might have been the lights to something
that was on the ground that's always
there well I'll get into that okay
because here's the thing from what I'm
from what I read of it later on like it
looks they don't want to believe it was
over there but yeah but I don't think
that most of the young people on the
base would have known that because I
don't know how familiar they were at the
area because like I said these were
American servers this is a key thing
yeah because the entire event starts
with this report yeah had this report
not happened the rest of the stuff
probably wouldn't have been reported
right if this report is just a report of
something it's on the ground
all right that's normally there then a
lot of this starts to fall apart yeah
because like I said I'm not a UFO buff
so I didn't have like I'd heard of this
and I think I saw someone the sci-fi
channel about like a long time ago and I
think you've talked about it a few times
but I didn't know like a huge amount of
the details about it but like the more
you read about it to me I know this is
kind of like the granddaddy of all like
UFO cases and stuff like that but I
don't know the more I realize I want to
stop you right there a lot of people
think this is the granddaddy of UFO K I
think there are much better ones much
just because there might be some
imperfections in this case doesn't
necessarily mean all the other cases are
false I really well yeah that doesn't
know that doesn't follow that right I
think this is a sensational case I think
it's flawed although I do think that
Colonel Holt saw some stuff yeah whether
or not he misidentified it I don't know
we're gonna get down with that yeah now
as I said at this stage I'm just telling
you what you know what the sequence of
events is usually reported as like on
the sci-fi channel documentary and what
the witnesses said many years later like
I said when I get into you know the end
I'll talk about what they actually said
at the time so I'm just this is the
story as it's popularly
convey'd okay so I'm just I don't
necessarily agree with all this stuff
but this is how it's usually played out
okay so Penniston and Burroughs they
report to the security Tower and they
said okay well you can take somebody
else and go out in the woods and see if
you can see if there's a downed aircraft
or whatever so they get this other guy
an airman his name is Edie cabins AG I'm
not sure pronouncing that right so they
go out into the woods and they okay so
they go out into the woods to
investigate this is yeah now
Penniston says and he said this later on
he said something like the air was
filled with electricity like he could
feel under your skin like you're you
know I'm assuming he means that static
electricity like your hair was standing
on and he reported that his their radio
stopped working
now Penniston said that he had a
notebook with him and that he saw this
craft that had landed in the forest and
he said that he he said it was about
nine feet by six feet it was triangular
come it was like made of like this glass
like it was very smooth and it had weird
symbols on the surface that he allegedly
drew in his notebook underneath this
alleged craft was a really strong bright
light that was pulsating and then like
red and blue lights around the edges
yeah and it wasn't it was hovering it
wasn't really standing on anything from
what I remember right well yeah but then
the next morning they said they found
landing like a tray in that spot yeah
okay that was that's the story so
they're talking about a small craft yeah
look like it's made of black glass the
size that they're talking about they're
talking about drone they're not talking
about something that would it be am and
you know I mean listen let's say alien
was the size of your hand maybe you know
wouldn't that be cute
yeah and he's he's vaguely saying it
kind of is a stealth craft in other
words geometrical kind of pointed
triangular shaped black that's kind of
like a stealth craft
yeah so this the description of the ship
if that you want to call her the probe
is vaguely like Earth technology yes or
inspired by earth technology if you ask
me okay now I kind of have my doubts
about this part of the sighting because
some other stuff comes into play but
okay what do you see up to that yeah so
evidently like I said he sketched these
this alleged craft in his alleged
notebook you'll know the reason that I'm
using that word somebody talks later off
but he allegedly bird in his alleged
notebook liftoff 245 no sound no air
disturbance takeoff unknown speed
impossible that's what he supposedly
wrote in this notebook at the time so
evidently they report it to one of their
higher-ups whose name was lieutenant
Fred bran now according to some accounts
they said oh there was a blip on the
radar about the same time that they saw
this craft that is a disputed assertion
so that so apparently these guys like
put in some reports
you know they sketched what they saw in
the sky at the time and then the next
morning like early the next morning they
decided you know when it was light out
they're gonna go to the clearing where
they supposedly saw this craft and see
if they could see anything that has the
report been put up by this point I'm not
really sure so they go to what is
assumed to be the same clearing they
said that they saw three indentations in
the ground that were in a perfect
isosceles triangle okay yeah and they
made plaster casts of them also now that
night which was I believe that December
26th or 27th I don't think anything
happened that night some sources state
that like another like an 18 year old
woman that had also worked on the base
that she saw like something that looked
like an orange fireball or something
like that but that's not usually part of
the official account but mostly then the
next night which was I
believe the I don't know who's the 27th
to 28th like I said the dates are really
kind of strange apparently they saw
lights again so they go and get Colonel
Charles halt who actually he was that
like a officers dinner probably like a
Christmas party or something like that
night this is yeah well it's actually
the third night because the second night
nothing really happened so apparently
this lieutenant named Bruce England like
rushes into the party and says it's back
you know come see it there's these weird
lights up in the sky so Colonel Charles
halt who was at time 41 years old
evidently he wasn't really buying it
he's like whatever but he decides
they're all gonna go out in the woods
and see what's going on now he actually
did take a microcassette recorder out
into the woods with him while they were
looking around they did not report
anything about lights or anything until
very very late the the the tape was only
about 17 18 minutes long because he
didn't leave it running the whole time
hits it's like he would tape for a
couple minutes and then turn it off and
tape work of his cities he didn't want
to run out of tape
but it's actually like a few hours where
they're like tramping around the
clearing where these alleged depressions
were and then they're kind of like going
across the field and seeing like what's
that
that first sighting yeah of the craft on
the ground on that first night
yeah this was documented into a report
and set up the chain to come in do you
know anything do you know anything about
that I mean it hadn't been reported
right because they told Hall to his back
they meant the lights were referring to
the lights that they saw at the gate
yeah not referring not referring to the
landed craft sighting because did they
report the landed craft no they didn't
one person I believe it was Penniston
and I'll get into this later he reported
I don't think he used the word craft but
I think he said that he saw something
metallic or something like that but he
saw it in the sky that's what I'm saying
about a lot of details being added like
later on okay because I don't think
anybody's original report it was just
weird lights like through the trees they
didn't nobody said anything
nothing was landed now there were
reports of like indentations in the soil
where this you know in this clearing but
you know there is an explanation for
that and like I said I've listened to
Colonel halts tape that he did on the
third night never heard the transcript
of it and he's pretty much agreed that
yeah that's what I said that's what we
were talking about you know what I mean
so there was that whole thing so they
apparently go and they says oh and then
there was like these marks on the trees
as though something came down you know a
lot of reports say with the radiation
levels were like ten times more than
normal and all this other kind of stuff
here's the thing that really kinda like
gets me with this case what the best
part of the most sensational part of
this whole report was seeing the little
black craft a little black triangular
space probe okay then gonna touch in it
and the symbols on it if you saw some
[ __ ] like that on duty and you didn't
report that you need to go to
Leavenworth right you know him not
reporting it I'm already gonna call
[ __ ] on it
well that father's on duty and I saw
some [ __ ] like that how would a damn
reported it yeah at that time yeah you
know I mean if reporting it later no
that's the same as saying you made it up
you have to report it at that time and
that's what that's what I'm saying
that's why even though this is touted as
like a really like credible case and
stuff like that a lot of the iconic
details of it likes it like the craft on
the ground you know Colonel halt saying
stuff like oh that he saw a craft and it
was like dripping like lava or something
like that a lot of that was a later okay
edition um if I'm on this nuclear
equipped base right to pull security
yeah okay 1980 dead of the Cold War yeah
and I see a black craft on the ground
hovering yeah you better report that
yeah it's a small probe or drone yeah
I'm gonna probably assume Soviet drone
yeah some kind of exotic technology of
course you're gonna report it because
see the thing about it the thing about
it too is that really as it was reported
in 1980 it was obviously not that big of
a deal because
everyone forgot about it until a tabloid
in the UK called news of the world found
Charles halts original memo that he
filed two weeks after the incident that
was just called unexplained lights it
wasn't called craft on the ground it
wasn't called later she called
unexplained lights that he had seen
through the trees and he filed that now
this tabloid got hold of it and
published it in 1983 added a bunch of
details put in some kind of implications
that maybe weren't really in the memo
stuff like that and that's when it
exploded it's like three years later
when it was published in a tabloid three
years later when it was published in a
tabloid vamped up yes yeah yeah so
here's the thing okay now as I said
that's kind of how the story goes with
it you know oh there's a craft a know it
had symbols on it and all this other
kind of stuff problem is if you listen
to the original tape that Charles halt
made on the third night and like I said
this wasn't the first night because he
wasn't there that night it's almost like
a different this is a different event
yeah now he did see unusual lights that
night it should be noted but the if you
go to I can't remember the name of the
scientist that wrote it but he wrote
like a three-page transcript of the
whole tape which you can find online and
the first two pages of the transcript
are like nothing all that unusual all
they're doing is they go to the clearing
where these depressions are and the
interesting thing is that Colonel halt
says on the tape when he sees the
depressions the first thing he says when
he sees him is that is that as big as
they are like so it's not really all
that impressive right
now it should be noted too that the cops
were called at the time and they looked
at these indentations and they said
there was no pattern to them so the
whole thing about the being like in a
perfect triangle and stuff was obviously
later the cops repeated dad said there
wasn't warning yeah the the police
report that was filed at the time said
they just looked like animals had done
it and he's most people that were
familiar with the area so it looked like
old rabbit burrows like a rabbit had
been digging around they were just
little I saw indentation I saw like any
looks old
I saw the casts and
look like it was depressions made by
something about the size of a volleyball
he asked me about that big around yeah
that's what it look like to me not very
deep right and then there was stuff and
you can actually hear on the tape you
can hear they have like a Geiger counter
type thing
now you could hear it clicking I'm not
really sure where this like ten times
higher radiation than normal came from
because the highest he ever registered
was like seven tenths which is like 0.07
like Miller roentgens or whatever they
call it which is pretty much background
radiation it didn't go any higher than
that on the tape because sometimes
they're like oh it's kind of clicking
like over here he's like oh what's the
reading on it it never went any higher
than 0.07 so it's not ten times higher
it was just regular background radiation
it did fluctuate exaggerated the
radiation but yeah so that's just what
happens they also were kind of talking
the first two pages of the transcript
they were also talking about the trees
around it and how they saw these marks
in the trees that maybe that was from
like a landed craft or whatever but even
then like Colonel halt says something
like oh they look old
yeah and later on when they talked to
foresters and sniffing works on there he
said they are old those are ax marks we
put those there to show that that tree
is ready for felling you know we're
gonna cut those trees down and sell them
to for timber and indeed those trees
were later cut down and sold for timber
just like you know the foresters were
like yeah that's how we mark them we put
a old axe mark in there and so that's
how we know that if we cut them down so
they cut them down so that was also
nothing and then the whole thing about
and I love this but the whole thing
about the lights through the trees and I
know that people who believe in like did
this happen and like in UFOs and stuff
we're gonna like I'm not gonna say swamp
gas but it's interesting to note that
the way that the lighthouse yeah it's
the lighthouse it's the lighthouse it's
in that exact I've seen and the way that
he describes the light on the tape yeah
cuz he's like oh look they see the light
there it is I see it again it's in the
sea I see it again so same it's a
five-second interval just like the
Orford ness lighthouse which was exactly
due east from where they were exactly
five miles away and he said that's about
where and he actually the younger kids
on
did not know that there was a lighthouse
there he knew there was a lighthouse but
he thought it was south east because he
was from the other base like he didn't
usually like he wasn't usually on that
base so he was still thinking it was to
the southeast right but no it's due east
from that particular base or where they
where they were cuz they've tracked them
on a map like where they were at this
particular time so they said all the
lights that they saw you know when they
saw this big white light that looked
like because he was kind of looking at
through binoculars or through a night
scope or something like that and he said
oh it's super bright and it looks like
it's winking or it looks like it's
darker in the middle they said well yeah
that would be the lighthouse like coming
around and then it would be blanking out
in the middle because the light was so
bright it was like the second brightest
lighthouse in the I think I've seen a
reconstruction where they take a camera
and shoot that lighthouse in low light
and then link it up with the tape and
he's gonna see that light yeah yeah
there there it comes again there it
comes again and it does it at that same
eye I think at that time at that in that
part of the of the tape I think they are
looking at the lighthouse yeah they
really don't seem to be because like I
said you can match it up exactly as soon
as the other person says on the tape
there it is again here comes the
lighthouse light again right and also it
should be noted that at one point
Colonel halt says that he sees five red
lights and that they're steady and then
they're not blinking and he sees them
like I think to the right of the main
light that's almost that's the
transmitting station for the which had
five radio towers with red lights on top
of them now the reconstruction I saw the
trees were mostly gone at that time but
maybe back then they were the trees were
higher yeah well they were closer to it
so yeah it's more obscured ya know what
you think happened yeah because if they
weren't seeing him real clearly because
if you look at like the the people that
um you know that saw it on the first
night they did actually sketch what they
thought the lights were and the best
sketch of it which only really one of
the one of the people saw and like
sketched it looked like something that
was mostly obscured by trees so you
wouldn't really it just kind of looked
like a really bright like pulsating
light like coming from between the trees
for
far away so that could have been
anything and honestly they were like a
lot of UFO sightings that particular
night that Christmas light but it should
also be noted that there was a very very
active meteor shower that night meteors
were reported actually from much earlier
that night which was Christmas night
there were some reported around 7:20 I
think there's some reported like right
after dark about 5:20 and then also
later on that night there was a Russian
rocket that had like deposited a
satellite and had broken up in the
atmosphere like right over that part of
England so some people had reported
seeing like kind of a fireball or
something coming back into the
atmosphere and that's what that was
because they knew where that was coming
from so any of the UFO reports that
happen because I you know I think some
of UFO sites say oh like a bunch of
people saw there were a bunch of UFO
reports I think there were like 200
something UFO reports that night you
know even before the Rendlesham forest
incident but most of that was meteors or
the you know the rocket breaking up when
it came back into the atmosphere seeing
them do the trees they're not actually
on a tape saying that it's moving
through the trees yeah that's not what
they said I came or later yet now they
did say that it looked like it was
moving but they were moving and the
light was moving they were walking
towards I'm probably right and honest
and it should be noted too that the
first night now this is before Colonel
halt was there before the tape or
anything like that two of the guys
Burroughs and the guy whose last name I
can't pronounce other guy other than
Pennington yeah those two guys pretty
much came out and said that it was the
lighthouse beacon okay I mean they
pretty much said we went out in the
woods and we were walking around and
then we realized that we were following
the lighthouse beacon they just hadn't
known but it just looked weird at the
time and then they find the black craft
on the ground is that during that not
well that was no their original report
original report yeah so it feels like as
the years went on and maybe like I said
after it was in the tabloid and after
this story like after they were out of
service yeah so I feel like they kept
adding details that show you know the
Air Force has no record of Penniston and
his buddy giving a report that describes
a little black craft not that I know of
now a lot of them have later on said as
they would that you know x-files oh it's
a big cover-up you know they took it
away and stuff like that but it should
be noted that even people that were
there at the time like I said one of the
guys that was there that night said no
it was the lighthouse and we thought it
was weird because we were looking for
the trees and it looked really strange
yeah but then we realized because they
didn't know the lighthouse was there but
then when they would say so oh it's a
lighthouse it's like circling around you
could see it from really far away okay
now what are the other reports now I
what I was going to say though is that
you know Jim Penniston later on said oh
I had this notebook with me and I and I
drew all these symbols and everything
but his buddy said he didn't have that
right it's like he didn't have a
notebook at the time we were just in the
thing we were following this light
nowheres now and then we went back to
the base and that was all that the thing
about the black craft Connor what made
me call [ __ ] on that a long time ago
so I thought it was only two guys that
went up and saw it turned out there were
three guys on that detail the third one
that got you that guy that you can't
pronounce his name yeah he wants nothing
to do with that story well yeah he says
I didn't see any of that okay I never
mentioned that yeah yeah they don't
never met yeah that's what I mean um he
just wanted to ban zag yeah he was the
one and he was there that first late so
they kind of make up the struggle oh
well he fell unconscious that's why he
didn't see it now see that's some
[ __ ] right there yeah he said now
according to his report this until years
later it's like I said I've seen all
three guys reports from the time yeah
okay
now his report says there was a single
pulsing light we saw through the trees
we thought it looked weird so we went
out after it and then we determined that
it was a lighthouse or like some kind of
light beacon and we went back to the
base and nothing happened that's the
that's the report they gave yeah that's
the original report yeah now like I said
looking good Penniston said that he saw
something through the trees that he
described could've been a craft but like
I said he just even the picture he drew
like could have anything it's not a
black triangle on the ground no then
yeah that's a big stretch now there was
another guy a one see Chris Arnold and
he was the one that called the cops and
he waited like at the end of the access
room for the cops to come they
interviewed him in 1997 and he said and
I quote
there was absolutely nothing in the
woods we could see lights in the
distance and it appeared unusual as it
was a sweeping light we did not know
about the lighthouse on the coast of the
time we also saw some strange colored
lights in the distance but were unable
to determine what they were contrary to
what some people assert at the time
almost none of us knew there was a
lighthouse at Orford ness so and like I
said the colored lights too could have
been there were a couple farmhouses over
there you could see the glow like over
the horizon and also there were five
radio towers about two miles to the
right of where the lighthouse would been
which was the transmitting station which
had five colored lights up on radiates
where radio towers getting back to that
third night Colonel Holt's out there he
sees the blinking lights he's doing his
recording I could have swore later on he
was saying it look like a that was
winking it looked like it was dripping
lava and sparks I didn't say lava until
late and then he says it looks like it
came out of the trees and went over by
the farmhouse and they kind of like blew
up into three other lights right and
then there were lights in the sky and
one of them shot down a laser at their
feet he did say something about one of
them looked like it had a beam coming
down like the stuff that he said on the
tape is really not dramatic okay um yeah
he said one it looks like a winking eye
it's weird-looking but like I said
that's kind of what a light and he was
looking through a scope at the time okay
um
which would have made the light super
super bright light coming through the
thing which might have been so it might
have been burning out in the middle
right which would have given you the the
eye effect he also did say yeah I see
like a bright light sort of near the
horizon there's like a beam coming down
but the thing about like astronomers
have said that Sirius and there were a
couple other stars in the sky that were
super super bright that night that were
very very close to the horizon and had
you seen them like through the trees
from that distance with all this other
light in the foreground it might have
looked like it was beaming I could have
sworn that a piece that he said that it
beamed down a light at their feet like
it was trying to communicate or
something no like I said I read the
transcript of the table and say nothing
on the tape is really all that
interesting so that kind of stuff was
said after it all happened yeah later on
and yeah and documentaries yeah so I
feel like what happened here like I said
after the tabloid picked up the story
because like I said no one really talked
about it from because it happened in
nineteen and of 1980 no one really it it
didn't really become a big thing until
1983 when news of the world kind of took
off with it they had a huge headline
that's in UFO lands and Suffolk and all
this other kind of stuff
so then it kind of hit the ground
running and then they start interviewing
you know and Colonel halt has been on a
bunch of things and you know summon Jim
Penniston and people like that have been
on a bunch of things but a bunch of
other people who were there that night
said there was absolutely nothing
unusual it's like we saw strange lights
in the woods we went to investigate we
figured out was the lighthouse wheeler
mentioned the base end of story
that was pretty much all that they said
how my my take on Colonel Holt is that
Colonel Holt was kind of like a typical
Air Force officer if you ask me he's
like Lieutenant Colonel mm-hm
they tend to be intelligent have kind of
like the kind of guys that would like
they would like Dungeons & Dragons you I
mean they like it they like tables and
numbers and graphs
you know they they're they're kinda
imagination type guys but they're also
kind of techie in a way yeah this is
pre-computer era you know I mean so
they're not quite techie by today's
standards but to me he struck me as
honest kind of nerdy guy ya know but
maybe what it was is that he kind of got
caught up in the emotions of the moment
withought with his his troops were you
know in a high state of awareness in a
high state of alert and they're excited
and maybe he conduct tries to convince
himself that this stuff is more
impressive than it really is so remember
there yeah I was where
you get kind of wrapped up in a
high-energy situation and something
happens and it seems super impressive at
the time but if you were to go back and
watch a video of it happening you go
you're like it you're like oh that's all
it was
I kind of feel like that's the situation
here I kind of feel like you know he
obviously thought it was a little bit
unusual at the time like the lights
looked unusual yeah he starts armed
himself up he's getting he's getting
excited about it he's like this isn't
normal
so then you know his imagination starts
to yeah well I think as they went on and
he kind of got you know famous in UFO
circles yeah I think it was I mean I'm
not saying that he's necessarily lying
or making it up I just think that he
convinced himself convinced himself
against him that he's making it more
exciting every time he tells I'd have
been a synergy of they kind of convinced
him that he saw more than what do you
really saw or that it looked a lot
cooler than it really did yeah cuz like
I said I've been in situations like yeah
it's like like I said I've read the tape
and it's like there's really I mean he
did not even seem impressed when they
first see the depressions in the ground
he's just like he was just kind of like
is that it you know is that them and
then even when he saw the marks on the
trees he's like they look old you know I
can see the SAP coming out of him he say
he's like it's a little weird but they
look old so he didn't he wasn't really
that impressed could be could be the
more time went on and the more he's
retelling this story and the more other
people are reacting to it with like wow
wow yeah he slowly kind of convinced him
that's what I think that this [ __ ] was
more more impressive than what it really
is memory is kind of malleable mm-hmm so
kind I think he's truthful I don't think
he's lying I don't think he is either I
think I've done it I think that over
time yeah his memories have kind of been
blown into it out of proportion about
what it really was and I think you know
at this point it's taken on a life of
its own and it's on like all these UFO
sites and everything so it's to his
advantage he goes and speaks in these
conferences and people are asking him
when do you saw the black craft and you
saw these weird lights and stuff like
that so it's to his advantage to well
story going he's also done you know not
in a negative way but just
it could it could be also he's seen
these recreations of the event and he's
remembering that and he's remembering
the recreation event goes yeah I guess
that's what it was yeah yeah I guess it
was that because that's what it was and
then over time his memories of the event
have kind of become merged with the
recreations of the event yeah that's
have been shown on television maybe at
the time at the time he wasn't that
impressed but as he saw the recreations
maybe he's like yeah maybe there was
something to that I read the thing of
him at the time like he seemed like blah
whatever like at the end when they
showed him delight he was like oh that's
weird but it didn't really sound like he
was like oh my god it's a UFO it wasn't
anything like that
but over time it became that because
other people were impressed so I think
he got caught up exactly then the memory
of what it really looked like slowly
gets replaced by the memory other people
are telling him to the recreations what
they're telling him it look like he's
like yeah that probably yeah that was
pretty weird yeah that's it right there
that's probably why I don't like he said
yeah and like I said the same thing
happened with Ronald Reagan he was he
would tell stories like I did this and
that but really it was like some [ __ ]
that happened in a movie you know he
never really did when was this yeah yeah
there was I can't remember like he did
it like several times but he forgotten
he forgot he was just acting a role yeah
he forgot that it was a movie and he
thought that it was something he really
really did and actually it wasn't even
necessarily movies that he was in it was
just movies that movie saw too that he
had just once he got older and kind of
got well yeah a lot of they don't
realize that yeah in his second term he
was his mind was so yeah so he would
like wasn't malicious he was just yeah
he would just like say stories that he
thought he remembered but they were
actually so I think that's kind of a
similar thing that's going on here I
think like the more it goes on the more
he gets encouraged you know by various
documentary filmmakers and you have go
buffs and stuff like that to more his
memories kind of change right what they
told him it is right that it was
replaced cuz as I said at the time the
report was even like the report he made
of two weeks after the incident which
like I said which is called unexplained
lights not classified in any way
they obviously didn't think it was
anything worth anything cops came and
looked at the you know for the lights
they said the only lights we can see her
from the lighthouse the cops came and
checked out the depressions they said
they don't look like anything looked
like animal it's easy to do I've told
this story several times on the show I
was in a guard tower over watching an
Egyptian civilian airstrip right outside
Sharm el-sheikh in the Gulf of Aqaba
part of our job was important to enforce
this UN peace tree by treaty no military
aircraft should have been landing at
this airport it was civilian stuff only
so I'm up there in that guard tower
watching that landing strip it's bored
boring boring boring maybe what plane
will land to every three or four days
now that's what kind of traffic it's a
little bitty airstrip I was writing a
letter doing something to reading the
magazine and I heard a noise off to my
right turned and looked and saw an
aircraft coming in for a landing and it
just overwhelmed me man I hit the
intercom and I said there's a military
aircraft landing and then it left my it
went behind some buildings didn't see
and they said what kind was it and I
said I don't know was it a jet or was
the prop plane and I go I think it was a
jet I said well how do you know it was
military and I was like I think it was
camouflaged and they said camouflage jet
I said how big was it and I said I think
it was like a Lear jet a camouflaged
military Learjet type thing and they
said we're sending a replacement up
there come down here you got to fill out
a report so I had a good sergeant at the
time named sergeant Smith and he's like
because I know when sometimes we get
shocked you can't really describe it
what was it really you know sighs I
don't know it was a military crap I tell
you that was military we're gonna get in
the vehicle we're gonna go down and
we're drive down we're gonna look at it
we got there it was a orange and black
c-130
which is a cargo plane look
was on it it was nothing much bigger
than a Learjet it was not camouflaged it
was painted up like a damn circus tent
orange white and black and it was
military at one time but it turn it was
you know it was bought by a civilian
company so that just goes to show you
how your memories can really be [ __ ]
up very quickly after seeing something
seriously if you're in a high state of
emotion so you are as they say fractally
wrong at least you knew it was a plane I
knew as a plane I knew this military you
didn't say it was like a hot air balloon
or anything after seeing that a lot of
that World War 1 camouflage called
dazzle did where they would paint these
weird patterns on ships and stuff to
kind of confuse your aim I could see how
that could probably work yeah cuz you
look at go whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
is that and you would have a hard time
identifying it because just if it
shocked you so that may have been what
Carl Holt is talking about something
similar that he saw it but his memory of
what he saw wasn't very distinct because
it probably wasn't that impressive but
then later having people repeating
alternate versions of it over and over
again seeing reacted is seeing
reenactments of that of it over and over
again it's kind of erased the original
memory and I always like to go back to
like original the original memos the
original newspaper reports original
anything because people like make up
[ __ ] ever this is like not maliciously
not on purpose memories nature that's
the way human memories work they're very
fallible yeah and I feel like that's
kind of the case here like I said I
don't know malice intended on anyone's
part I'm sure it's just that over the
years details have been added but like I
said some of the people that were there
at the time you know have said look we
just saw weird light in the woods we
followed it it was a lighthouse
end of story that's all that happened we
didn't see any craft in the woods
nothing like that happened there was no
weird symbols nothing like that and the
interesting thing too is that you know
as the years have gone on I guess to get
over the cognitive dissonance you know a
lot of them will say oh well our
original reports were covered up or
I believe a couple of the witnesses say
they've been threatened like you know
high military higher-ups have told them
bullets are cheap and stuff like that
but I'm like well they're not stopping
you from going on the sci-fi channel and
talking about it because obviously you'd
be dead by this one there's one there's
one witness that I think's lying he said
that he saw it land in another spot too
and it was a triangle and ghost alien
spirits came out of it they had faces
and they were bullying there's a whole
film crew filming it and it was like
something my Close Encounters of the
Third Kind and they silenced everybody
in town you know it was my job to lose
my job to work in military bases all
right including Fort Campbell and Camp
grieves up in Korea the second I D first
the 506 which is right where they have
those peace talks with the North Koreans
isn't back in the first Gulf War telling
you you can't get away with anything on
those things back because everybody's
everywhere and everybody's watching
everybody yeah I mean and you know and
and soldiers and airmen and servicemen
they're like [ __ ] man you talk about
you talk about talk you can't keep a
secret there yeah those guys of gossip
they'll gossip harder than any woman you
can't keep a secret there you know every
I've always found men to be working
gossips women I mean in my experience
and if if there was aliens and [ __ ]
going on there man you did they would
have all known to been down there with
cameras and if it's and when we were on
the DMZ we got photographs of some [ __ ]
that you photographs that it really
should have never happened
it's a different world psyche a price to
tell it now I have pictures of ketosis
that we knew shaking hands and hug and
North Korean soldiers across the D MDL
on the outside yeah which they could go
to prison for that and those North
Koreans could probably executed for that
we had photographs of it yeah of them
hanging out yeah
smoking cigarettes and we used to trade
across that MDL those guys are all gone
the tensions going away like I said I
think the funniest thing to me and
especially like I said it's why I'm not
a real big believer in these big
conspiracy
there's and stuff like that because it
always seems like people will come on a
sci-fi documentary that millions of
people watch and go if anybody knew
they'd have me killed I'm like dude you
were on a millions of people who are
watching it right now and you were still
alive if they wanted you dead you'd be
dead already
believe me they would he would be is if
they cared about what you were saying
you'd be dead already they wouldn't let
you go on anything such a secret like
like that involving aliens as safe there
were aliens it wouldn't be done by the
military it would be it would be private
contractors yeah you can't trust guys in
service eh 18 19 20 year old guys have
glad well and that's something too that
a lot of people forget is that the the
three guys that initially saw the weird
lights I mean these are like 1922 foods
they're kids yeah pretty much you could
trust them with physical things but you
can't trust them with things like aliens
and crap like that that's gonna be guys
that are contracted by in echelon it's
above reality something happen to do
with the CIA or dia something like that
it's gonna be a shadowy civilian group
well no guys with ex-military
backgrounds in a government group but
they don't wear uniforms and they're not
around anything military it's it's you
know I mean a lot higher security than
that in other words a invisible [ __ ]
yeah visible [ __ ] yeah so like I said a
Rendlesham forest it's as much as and I
don't know much about UFO lore or
anything like that but even I had heard
of this incident it had seen some stuff
on documentaries about it but as I said
the more I died the more I looked into
it the more I read the original memos
from the time and stuff yes you could
come out and say Oh they've been
falsified blah-dee-blah
but it's interesting to me that some
people that were there at the time said
look there's nothing there was nothing
there it was like nothing that big of a
deal we knew exactly what it was after a
few minutes yes it looked weird to start
with but then we figured out what it was
and that was all there was to it and a
lot of this stuff was kind of added
later on just like a lot of the [ __ ]
that we talked about with the mass
hysteria stuff and the cool [ __ ] was
added on later on by guys that have yeah
they're left service yeah that they're
out of it
they can't be punished that's why I'm
saying why didn't they were the reason
why they didn't report the black craft
on the ground during that time period
because had they reported that that have
been their ass yeah you'd have gotten a
lot of trouble yeah
you can't put up a false report well
probably because they didn't think of it
so once they got out they could say that
yeah later on they'd be like what yeah
according to later and we were only
there for a couple minutes past two or
three years that Sam guy what's his name
oh no no um Penniston yes
Penniston says in that notebook or in
another notebook there's a bunch of
zeros and ones that he wrote down which
was a code that he was in his head that
he got from the the alien download it's
a secret yeah the alien download that
came out like a couple years ago so like
I said people they just watch this I
said that this aspect of the case is
pretty bad although I think Holtz saw
the delights and I think that was the
tower and the and the Delano lighthouse
see that's the thing that I got caught
up in them on if you know if all you did
you just saw some weird lights in the
sky that could have been anything you
don't get to be on TV yeah [ __ ]
you have to like well he didn't make it
up I think like I said I think he kind
of got manipulated in it although I'm
not saying that there's no I believe
that there are extraterrestrial craft
come every now and then if that's what
you want to call them craft they may not
be craft I might be the
extra-terrestrial itself I don't now
there's a better case known was the
triangle over Illinois that all the cut
that those two or three cop yeah
different police stations saw it that
one cop got a photograph of it with a
Polaroid camera it was in the back of
trunk and you can see with three red
lights but that's it you know yeah the
thing is is whether or not was that
extraterrestrial I think that might have
been somehow stealth believe you take a
stealth blimp and you put a bunch of LED
lights on it back and before LED lights
were common and you you you you light it
in a way to make it look like an
extraterrestrial craft so when you see
it you're totally dazzled and
you think it's an alien craft not a not
a reconnaissance that one yeah and then
when you report it to the police you say
weird look like oh I have lights on the
corners it was triangle on the back it
had a pulsing bars it was an alien crap
you know man get out of here they don't
want to hear that [ __ ] well so that
would be an excellent camouflage to take
a platform like that and make it look
like an extraterrestrial craft it'll
dazzle the hell out of you when you go
to report it the reports wouldn't be
believed yeah we'll just think your own
I think you're crazy so you could take a
plumber you could take a craft like that
like a stealth Zeppelin that could hover
and it's quiet and you could put that
into enemy airspace and people would see
it and not react they just stand there
with their jaws you know open that's an
alien craft and then they kind of be
afraid to report it that's a hell of a
camouflage well like you said if you see
something that unexpected you're not
gonna remember it right there any
dazzled and then you go how do I report
this that's how come like that's how
come when when you know a crime is
committed and a lot of people see it
like their description of the
perpetrator and like differs wildly
because well in this case though the
cops uniformly described it pretty
accurate but the thing is they're not
believed even to this day yeah so that's
a hell of a camouflage but the thing
about go in there and with impunity and
be seen and not believed but the thing
about that case was that it wasn't super
crappy they didn't say there was a
little grey alien though they took it
stuck a probe up my bot or anything like
that they were like just bait so I saw a
weird lights in the sky that could have
been an alien craft it could have been
no like some kind of stealth tech knows
that some pretty much one of the cops
saw it at a few hundred feet away yeah
about a hundred feet off the ground
buzzing and it was trying to learn it
had a pattern on it and then it took off
at a high rate of speed low across the
fields the acceleration was good and it
was quiet some people might say well
that's got to be alien
[Music]
a buoyant aircraft like a solid body
Zeppelin under the right circumstances
with the right kind of propellers and if
they're especially if they're silenced
and they're inside of the craft you
could probably get that to move pretty
quick pretty quietly and you know that
buzzing sound I think might have been
the sounds of propellers but you know
imagine that propellers were inside the
craft yeah no yeah it's bringing in air
through vents and blowing it out through
the back yeah you know they keep the
sound down
there'd be a hell of craft yeah yeah
good imagine a solid body Zeppelin that
semi weightless even with propellers
would probably pretty quick I bet you
can it could climb like crazy because
it's lighter than air yeah
lighter-than-air craft no kind of
getting off topic I was just thinking
that like you know the whole story of
the Christmas star and no room at the
inn and [ __ ] it's like that's kind of
like the oldest yeah I just wanted to
relate it back to Christmas before you
say that that was a UFO but that's not
what they're talking about no I know
it's not like I said I'm just I was
trying to relate it but I'm not sure my
mouth cherubim and Seraphim and stuff
okay all the three wise men see any UFO
presence the lights in it rig goes
around then it points out down to where
the baby is right here Burt Burt yes I
challenge you follow a star and see what
the stars pointed to any night it was
God's flashlight that's what that was
but anyway okay so we've got on like
long enough about all of these crazy UFO
stories that all happened around
Christmas time as a matter of fact hope
you guys have enjoyed this special
Christmas edition of the 13 o'clock
podcast and hopefully you had a lovely
Christmas or holiday or whatever it is
that you celebrate with your family with
lots of food with presents with cool
[ __ ] like that and hopefully
we we were part of your holidays that'd
be kind of nice and remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media share with all your
friends and family and if you'd like to
financially support the show go to our
patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast stop
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation if you
want more Christmas goodness you can
check out our last movie retrospective
which was a Christmas double feature of
Christmas evil and the Christmas
Chronicles serving across a lot that
will do it for our Christmas special
episode 123 and we will see you next
time Merry Christmas everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]